según la real academia española de la
lengua un centro es un lugar donde
convergen informaciones o decisiones por
tanto y extrapolando de esta definición
un centro educativo no solo debería ser
un lugar donde se imparten clases sino
también un lugar donde tomar decisiones
y llegar a acuerdos sobre cómo deben
llevarse a cabo esas clases sobre el
funcionamiento general del centro y el
rol de las personas que lo habitan en
definitiva un centro educativo es un
lugar donde tanto alumnado como
profesorado padres y personal de la
administración ocupan una posición
importante
esto es un centro educativo o por lo
menos debería ser así pero todos sabemos
la realidad y si miramos hacia atrás
teniendo en cuenta nuestra experiencia
educativa sólo unos pocos de nosotros
serán los afortunados que podrán decir
que estudiarán en un centro educativo
como el que acabamos de definir la
mayoría solo hemos ido al colegio al
instituto lugares donde simplemente el
profesor impartía clases y el alumno las
recibía
pero qué ocurriría si la comunicación y
la relación entre alumnado y profesorado
se convirtiese en un flujo natural que
inundarse los pasillos del centro
educativo de tal manera que el proceso
de aprendizaje acabe siendo un proceso
bidireccional en el que el profesor
también retroalimenta del alumno qué
ocurriría si cada uno de los rincones
del centro educativo se llenase de
aprendizaje de tal manera que el papel
del alumnado cobrase mayor importancia
así obtenemos el papel del alumno tutor
que está presente en muchos centros
educativos sin embargo no somos
conscientes de ello cada vez son más los
centros donde se trabaja en equipo por
su eficacia frente al trabajo
competitivo e individualista con ese
trabajo en equipo se consigue una mayor
relación entre entre los alumnos y así
la tutoría entre iguales en la que se
según diría a cicerón hace más de 2000
años si quieres aprender enseña
esta tutoría entre iguales garantiza una
mejor cohesión entre aquellos alumnos de
tal manera que no sólo se consiguen unos
beneficios académicos sino también unos
beneficios a nivel social personal y
emocional pues se establece una relación
de empatía clave entre esos dos alumnos
en mi caso yo he sido alumno tutor
gracias a la música y en particular hago
a un proyecto músico educativo formado
por jóvenes que pretendemos llevar ese
aprendizaje entre iguales del que
hablábamos al principio tanto a las
aulas de colegios institutos como de
escuelas de música y conservatorios el
origen de todo esto se remonta a cuando
yo estudiaba en la escuela de música de
mi pueblo un lugar donde se trabajaba de
manera totalmente diferente a lo que
solemos imaginar cuando hablamos de
escuelas de música un centro innovador
en el que no existían barreras entre
alumnos y profesores donde se defendía
el trabajo basado en proyectos y el
trabajo y participación activa de toda
la comunidad educativa
cuando tenía 16 años un grupo de
compañeros y yo decidimos embarcarnos en
este proyecto y así poder difundir esta
filosofía de educación por nuestra
propia cuenta y por otras escuelas de
música tales como las de toledo
torrelavega barcelona tanto que incluso
llegamos a cruzar al otro lado del
charco durante 15 días estoy mostrando
nuestro trabajo a diversos institutos de
california hoy en día cuando vamos a un
colegio o una escuela de música
utilizamos como principal herramienta
espectáculos musicales que nosotros
mismos creamos todos ellos garantizan
una mayor cuestión y trabajo de igual a
igual de toda la comunidad educativa
este cambio hacia una educación integral
debe estar liderado por los jóvenes pues
formamos las generaciones futuras pero
no sólo a través de la música sino
también a través de cualquier otra
disciplina que les permita aportar a un
proyecto común por tanto dejemos que los
alumnos tomen las riendas para que creen
así su propia educación y componga su
futuro muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]